if you ever heard of the 80/20 rule
while its roots are in economics and
process improvement its found its way
into popular culture the basic idea is
that with everything we are trying to
improve 80% of the problem or
opportunity lies with 20% of the reasons
so what is a Pareto chart well let's
take a look a putter chart is both a bar
and a line chart so we're gonna draw
this up and it has two axes so there's
the y axis on the left hand side you got
our x axis and then we've got another y
axis on the right hand side on the right
hand side is the percentage in which
something occurs so we're just going to
try to keep that simple here we'll put a
hundred percent 50% and then just down
here at zero on the left hand side this
is the frequency in which an issue
occurs so again we'll be trying to keep
it simple here we'll go with ten five
and that would be zero and then along
the bottom we list the the categories or
defects of issues that we're seeing so a
b c d e I'll just put the defects now as
we're tracking our data from a
collection form we'll look at it and
I'll say well gosh how many do we have
of each of these and we try to list
these in the order in which is most
frequent to least frequent so it's
showing you from big to small so if we
think of defect a let's imagine that we
had eight of defect a defect B we had
five defect C we only had about three
defect D there was maybe two and defect
a had one all right so again well
and then there's another piece it's a
line chart and that's where the
percentages come in and what we're
trying to do is identify what percentage
of the total problem is each of the
defects so we can try to see which is
the the most common deletes common order
looking for that that 8020 rule so
imagine we've got this line chart and
we'll just say that if this is 80 here
if we work on this particular defect we
can expect that we can actually make the
biggest improvement in our process and
so it's a great place for us to start
doing our PDSA testing and some of our
other tools and methods to identify
opportunities for improvement so the
idea here is to look at the issues with
the biggest effect the vital few 20% and
focus your improvements there first
if successful your initial improvements
will make the biggest difference Pareto
charts are very easy to create in any
spreadsheet program and are helpful for
converting check sheet and
cause-and-effect data into knowledge it
helps focus improvement efforts on the
vital few opportunities for improvement
and can help you make a big impact
you